our short National sartorial nightmare
is over as the U.S Senate officially and
unanimously votes to make John fetterman
get dressed before coming to work at
these supposedly greatest deliberative
body in the world
a bipartisan resolution titled the show
our respect to the Senate act the shorts
act
s-h-o it was somewhat labored but they
call it the shorts act it was put
forward by Democrat Joe manchin and sort
of Republican Mitt Romney requiring that
male Senators wear a quote tie and
slacks or other long pants on the senate
floor or else risk removal by the
Sergeant at Arms
the shorts Act is the most productive
legislative work that the U.S Senate has
done this term
the Senators can't figure out how to fix
the Border crisis or revive the economy
or even fund the government but they
have finally now at least figured out
how to dress themselves
which is a good start right now head on
over to puretalk.com Knowles you know a
company is looking out for you when they
actually upgrade your service and don't
charge you for it this is great news for
new and current Pure Talk customers pure
talk just added data to every plan and
includes a mobile hotspot with no price
increase whatsoever if you have
considered pure talk before but have not
made the switch take a look again for
just twenty dollars a month you will get
unlimited talk text and now fifty
percent five zero percent more 5G data
plus their new mobile hotspot
this is why I love Pure Talk they're
veteran owned they only hire the best
customer service team located right here
in the USA most families are saving
almost a thousand dollars a year while
enjoying the most Dependable 5G Network
in America
remember when you vote
you can vote with your ballot and you
can vote with your money so stop
supporting woke wireless companies that
don't support you when you go to
puretalk.com Knowles you will save an
additional fifty five zero percent off
your first month because they value you
that is puretalk.com Knowles Pure Talk
Wireless for Americans by Americans we
have some breaking news right now which
is that Senator Dianne Feinstein has
died
a Dianne Feinstein was up there in years
people have called on her to retire in
recent years I have not Dianne Feinstein
was a big Democrat certainly I've always
kind of liked her I I
have said for months now I did not want
her to retire at all I actually was
endorsing her for about three more terms
because she's much better than anything
else we were going to get out of
California
she she had a many decades-long
political career
there were some uh Infamous moments
along the way that conservatives had a
lot of fun with like when uh Senator
Feinstein grilled Amy Coney Barrett over
whether or not the Dogma lived loudly
within her and so there were these
moments as there are for every
politician where people would always
just focus on them but broadly speaking
they come a lot worse than Dianne
Feinstein as far as Democrat Senators go
Dianne Feinstein was was really one of
my favorites and I love that she stuck
it out until the end and refused to
retire or resign even as many members of
her own party were trying to force her
to and so certainly pray for the Repose
of her soul and uh and pray for whoever
comes next in California who almost
certainly will be much much worse than
Dianne Feinstein the the
politically significant aspect of her
death
is this look Diane she lived a good long
life you know it's it's not as though
she was cut down in her prime in her 20s
she lived a good long life a very uh
respectable career as a U.S senator uh
but what it means for us is that
we have a gerontocracy I'm not even
saying that's a terrible thing but our
country is run by very aged people
people who are older even than usual in
the Senate you know the word Senate
comes from Senex which means old man but
even still by historical standards we
have an aged group of people running the
country and that means that at any
moment
they could die
not wishing ill on any of these people
but Mitch McConnell is up there in years
Schumer's up there in years Joe Biden
obviously up there in years even Donald
Trump he seems a lot more vigorous than
the rest of them but he's no spring
chicken and so
the advantage of having older people
running the show is that they do have
more wisdom we Hope they've certainly
had more experience I'm not one of these
people who's totally opposed to old guys
running things but it does open you up
to the potential of real chaos if
someone happens to die it it is entirely
possible that the incumbent president as
he seeks reelection might not make it
for health reasons
and in that case what what will happen
this is something I've said as the flip
side of our gerontocracy for a long time
which is the longer this goes on the
longer that the Boomers and the silent
generation hold on to power the more
radical the transformation will be when
the younger generation takes over
because the younger generation as always
views things a little bit differently
than the older generation do and and we
have had a period of relative stability
in the way that we view our own
political order and in our rhetoric
because it's been the same people
running the show for 50 years but that
is that is an illusion that is going to
go away
the moment that these people go away
so the Senate will continue on at least
now they've figured out how to dress
themselves and John Federman will have
to put on a suit for work speaking of
men at work I didn't get to it yesterday
but I do want to touch on this while the
undercard was debating at the Reagan
Library for the Republican primary
nomination battle
Donald Trump went to Michigan to Rally
with striking Auto Workers here was his
message crooked Joe and his payday with
the Biden family they raked in millions
and millions of dollars you see what's
going on the news doesn't really
reported very little news reports it but
it was the men and women who got every
single day they got up and came back
home with grease in their hands and they
were the ones that paid the price they
paid a big big price the only time Joe
Biden has ever gotten his hands dirty is
when he's taking cash from foreign
countries which is quite often actually
it's quite often
it's a good line it's the only time
Joe's ever gotten his hands dirty okay
uh what do we take away from this speech
the speech went well it was a good as
far as rallies go was good uh
I don't think it made a ton of news
I I don't know that it distracted too
much attention from the GOP undercard
debate but I don't know that that many
people watched the GOP undercard debate
and I don't think that that debate
really moved the needle for anyone
people performed basically as expected
some people underperformed I felt Nikki
hurt herself I felt Tim Scott kind of
hurt himself uh DeSantis did well as
expected Vivek did basically as well as
expected so I don't think it really
moved the needle so what do we conclude
from the Trump event we conclude that he
is running in the general election
already this rally was focused on Joe
Biden crooked Joe the only time he's
ever gotten his hands dirty is when he's
taking money so he he is focused he is
behaving as though the primary were
already over and the primary is not
already over but every indication would
suggest that Donald Trump is going to be
the nominee
the national polls the state polls the
number of committed delegates in for
instance the Iowa caucuses the the
relative lack of change for the polls
over time so it's probably smart for
Trump to focus on the general election
but he's still going to have this he's
still going to have this primary and as
as we have seen today uh anything
anything can happen boy what a great
clip that was now make sure that you
ring the bell subscribe to the Michael
Knowles YouTube channel we'll see you
next time